foreign
2015. I may be getting this right blog
post
2354 words I believe
so this is this is the big one this is
the motherload and my question is
before the blog post became the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ] what other
names did you consider for that if you
even remember
Endor how did you just end up with title
because
I you think a lot about word smithing
and and crafting and I know you spent
time on this and I know you have spent a
lot of time thinking about
headlines and titles so
what was the process of getting to that
so just there's not really a way to
answer that without kind of going back a
little bit and talking about
what that era of social media was and
what kind of my whole process was back
then great
I think I had my first like Mega viral
Post in 2012 early 2013 and
what I don't think it took a while for
everybody to figure out but it was right
around then that Facebook
turned on the spigot of reach for
outside published material like Facebook
kind of decided that they wanted to be
the newspaper for everybody
and so if you were able to write
an attention-grabbing headline
you know a little bit of copy have a
intriguing image
you would just go crazy on that platform
and so
the big growth spurt that happened in my
audience was on Facebook from 2013 to
2015 subtle art was actually one of the
last
viral articles I had in a series of
probably eight or ten by our very viral
articles over that two-year period
I kind of discovered this and then
started refining a process and as you
pointed out like a huge part of the
process was title I just realized like
the title is almost as important as the
entire article itself so I started
spending hours just writing out
dozens and dozens of titles
and I also just kept around title ideas
that I had
you know I just had a Google doc that
I'd be out at dinner with a friend and
he'd make a joke and I'm like ah that'd
be a really good article title and I'd
like pull out my phone and jot it down
on the Google Docs so
the subtle art the title had been
sitting on that Google doc for a while
so I'm a big metal fan
and the
the band Lamb of God has a song called
the subtle art of murder and persuasion
and it was right around that time I
forget I had a couple articles with
another thing about Facebook's algorithm
at the time I noticed that if I just put
[ __ ] in the title you know you would get
like 50 more juice turbo boost yeah
exactly it was like a cheat code for
Facebook my mind was already in a spot
where I'm like looking back in the
wholesome good old days
oh my God
so you know my mind I was already kind
of existing in a headspace where I'm
always on the lookout for like a clever
use of the f word and and so I was
listening I was huge fan of Lamb of God
and that song comes on on my my iPhone
or whatever the subtle art of murder and
persuasion and I was like the subtle art
of not giving a [ __ ] I was like wow
that's that's really catchy and then it
sat on the document for a while and then
it's actually funny kind of how the
article got written
it sat there for many months it never
really
I never really felt the inspiration to
do something with it and then there was
a period
that holiday the Christmas and New
Year's right before that that like as
you said it came out January 8th that
holiday was really shitty for a variety
of personal reasons
it was just one of those Christmas
holidays that you're like [ __ ] why do I
have a family and
like do I have to spend time with these
people so
you know I was coming out of that in a
pretty bummed out State yeah my wife who
I was not engaged to yet at the time
there was like Visa trouble so she was
you know stuck in Brazil so I'm like
basically I was actually in Austin I was
sitting alone like basically just moping
in Austin for a few weeks and when I get
mopey I get very very snarky and like
like bitingly sarcastic and so
it was time to write an article and I
pull up the list and I see that title
and I'm like you know what I'm going to
write the most offensive
profane thing I can possibly imagine but
I'm also going to
give the best possible advice that I
I imagine I can give I'm going to
combine the two things and I just want
to create that like dissonance in people
and so I wrote it and I thought it was
completely over the top and ridiculous
and you know sometimes when you write
something
I'm sure you have this experience like
you're you can't really tell if it's
good or not like yeah you're too close
to it yeah so I put it away I woke up
the next day I was still unsure about it
and I sent it to my content guy official
title
and I told him who also kind of acts as
an editor for me and I told him I was
like I don't even know if I want to post
this it's pretty ridiculous and he came
back on slack in like all caps and he
was like you can fire me I'm posting
this [ __ ] thing he's like this is the
best thing we have to post this
and sure enough he was right like it
just it went absolutely crazy
it was everywhere